[Applaudissements]
je suis bon
dérogation ah non
voilà
salut pas tout
[Applaudissements]
j'adore
quand allez vous installer mon égal de
quelques dégâts comme à salavaux pürro
et écoutant je regardais la meilleure
émission pour la fin de la promo de
semaine
on l'a gardé parce que parce que c'est
parce que j'ai même pas la fin de ma
phrase qu'est-ce que supporter je les
aime tous se serait vu cadel mal et ils
arrivent ils sautent pas y figureraient
la sylve bonjour merci mes deux les deux
se sont expliqués tie break ce soit si
on dirait qu'on alors s'avéra déjeuner
excuse moi tu as des ipad
non
ouais je lui dis je lui excuse moi y'a
jean-luc laïque a appelé la mère et/ou
correspondent ou non merci m'a dit wen
talent à ghadamès verrait bien coûter
loi en fait nous ont fait pas partie de
ses invités qui rentrent ils verront il
s'assoira il s'attend pas une question
est pourquoi il faut qu'on vote
on est dans l'émission
[Applaudissements]
on va et on monte des ja du public mais
ces deux buts c'est une émission où je
me mets la mettant sur les genoux danois
ça va ça va mais je suis très très
heureux je retrouve l'équipe je retrouve
le réalisateur qui m'a offert le rôle
pense le plus drôle que jamais dans
l'est de ma vie merci française vous
avez tourné plusieurs semaines ensemble
et on va faire lequel des cinq si
l'interview je vous donnais des phrases
vous allez dire c'est arrivé à qui et
surtout de la table lequel des cinq a
déjà tourné tout nu dans un film qui a
déjà tourné tout nu dans un film avec
cran c'est franck gastambide c'est vrai
mais pas longtemps longtemps mais bien
longtemps mais très très bien même il
faut laisser le dossier h et j'ai vu le
dossier
non c'est pas comme si c'était un peu
toute première fois toute première fois
et jeanne mas n'ont pas bronché 3 et
voilà dangereux cobra le père est un
film quoi c'est un film bien ferro tient
non pas du tout c'est comme un levier
avec camille comme j'étais venu ici si
on dirait une vidéothèque et b mais vous
aviez beau tout nu c'est vrai les abdos
il met que des photos de beaux gosses
c'est vrai c'est un truc de fou
moi aussi j'en ai cherchés de moi mais
j'ai pas
[Rires]
ce qu'on n'a pas
gbagbo si vous mettez des photos de
beaux gosses sur les rhénans on dirait
un gars de faites entrer l'accusé
le gall genre dirait il était médecin
c'est un poteau d'un gars qui a été tué
dans une émission sur france 3 une
émission sur france 3 ce gars était tué
chalet 845 bâton coups de bâton de 6,40
au débat je vais la garder
je vais regarder derrière moi toutes les
missions et vivait en france mettaient
pas français est un prénom devient
mugler
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ja
en plus
merci m année qui sont les 8e en battant
l'as cannes et watania nom d'agathe gad
garde et la luxueuse gauche parce qu'il
ya une scène il ya une scène paul
meilhat et on était tous au tous autour
est tout autre à regarder donc à devoir
payer à gad elmaleh qui étaient à bord
au très joli gars tu postes au motif
qu'ils souhaitent est-ce que ce que le
pataquès là c'est qu'on va tous faire
ensemble a déjà fait jamais fait à
l'étranger et gérer que vous mangez des
choses bizarres la pluie alors lui lui
manquera mais vous il les a un problème
on a pu déjà tu connais pas ma vie donc
tu me juge pas j'ai un problème depuis
longtemps
franchement de parler de ça à la télé sa
mort
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
malu malu que tu viens ici man à chaque
fois saluer passe et combat look déjà
c'est rachid a très bien s'avérer aussi
et surtout parce que c'est vrai que vous
ça va calmez vous est-ce qu'on peut
revoir la fiche parce que je crois que
j'ai ce tu peux c'est juste mon vérifiez
vous n'êtes pas sur la fiche voilà vous
êtes là bas on va sur le joueur est
d'accord mais j'ai un débris ce qui
vient de se passer de gamme je prends de
franck
mais jean michel eeckhout blessés hier
jean-michel on va regarder d'abord s'il
y avait ici c'est quoi le débrief la
déco était bien et un débrief quand même
ouais c'est toi qui est formidable
votre prénom c'est comment maintenant
oui oui mais merci quand il avait pris à
me raconter sa vie mais aussi son rêve
justement on a ouvert le rideau
moi j'étais à la hauteur de gori
[Applaudissements]
toutefois comme un fait ça